hey what's happening people of the
internets it's dr john dolone here with
ramsay network today we are talking
about what do you do
when a parent who left you high and dry
reaches out and wants to reconcile so i
got an email to ask john ramsey
solutions.com
i'm going to read it to you today here
we go
dr d what's up what's up rolling in my
5.0 with my rack top down so my hair can
blow all that
hope you're doing well i am you too i'm
writing
to you to get some advice on my fiance's
lack of relationship with her mother
due to poor decisions made by her mother
when my fiance was young
her mother was removed from her life and
her dad raised her quite
excellently excellently is not a word
but i appreciate your
you're going for it there quite
excellently for a single dad they hadn't
had communication for nearly a decade
and recently she's been reaching out to
her on social media to try to reconnect
and she even suggested they meet for
lunch sometime
i've always known about her childhood
and i assume this would happen
eventually
i just thought or really hoped it would
be later in life we just graduated
college and are starting new jobs in
separate towns about two hours apart
while they're planning our wedding
that is in six months our relationship
is healthy
and we're going through some premarital
counseling i want to encourage
reconciliation but at the same time
i could also see negative effects coming
from that you're right
and you're right i love my fiance and
i'll work through anything relationally
but i'm not sure
how to start talking through this with
her awesome great question
good for you for being a fiance that
cares about his future relationship and
more importantly
cares about his future wife way to go
dude you get a gold dude star so now
that we have the internets
parents who were separated from their
kids whether it's because of adoption or
whether it's because
they had addiction issues and courts
took them away or whether there was
abuse
sexual abuse physical abuse emotional
abuse there was separation
man now you can just google find
facebook's find the interwebs and people
are tracking each other down
so if you've been separated from your
birth parents this is gonna happen to
you
more than likely this video is for folks
whose parents were addicts when they
were young and now they're clean
this video is for the dad who cheated on
mom
and he took off with the secretary and
now he's back after 10 years or 15 years
or 20 years
this video is for folks whose parents
were religious zealots
and now they've changed their hearts and
minds and they want to have
relationships this video is for folks
whose parents were
uber angry or super avoidant or
were hyper critical and now they
desperately want a relationship
what do you do when you get that first
facebook post or that instagram post
that says hey
this is your mom i'd love to talk so
here are four things you've got to
consider when you are thinking about
reconciliation number one
you got to let the fantasy go
you're not going to have a great
conversation and everyone's going to
head off to chuck e cheese that's not
how these
things go you're not going to get back
old birthday parties you're not going to
get back
learning how to ride a bicycle with your
dad in the cul-de-sac at the end of your
street and firework shows and all of
that
that stuff is gone a parent's job
a parent's job is to teach their kids
how to connect
how to love and be loved well and for
whatever reason
if you're watching this video your
parents did not do that this person
wasn't your mom this wasn't your dad
they were maybe your mother or your
father right they gave birth to you
but they didn't raise you and so you
have to know that in many ways you are
meeting a stranger
so you've got to let the fantasy go
number two be clear about why you want
to meet
are you just curious do you want to know
about your heritage
have you actually forgiven your birth
parent and you just want to circle up
and say hey
we're adults and i want to build a
relationship going this way
or do you want to show up and just ready
to unload
like a like a scene from some dramatized
lifetime movie
where you say the good thing and they
cry and then you hug at the end
none of that's gonna happen okay so you
have to ask yourself
why if you're going to a reconciliation
conversation
or you choose to meet your mom at
mcdonald's and your only reason to go is
to fight and yell
and show them how angry you are and tell
them the things
you're going to leave angry you're going
to leave hurt you're going to leave
empty
so ask yourself why do you want to have
this meeting why do you want to
reconcile why do you want to
come back together number three if you
choose to go ahead and meet in person
if you choose to be in contact
electronically or to make a phone call
you choose the boundaries and the terms
period you choose when and where the
meeting is going to happen
you choose when and where you're going
to communicate and how you're going to
communicate
you decide if this person is going to
get your cell number or your home
address
if they're going to meet your kids if
they're going to find out you have a dog
if they're going to know where you work
all of that
is on your terms the temptation when
you're running to see
an old parent an old birth mother an old
birth father
is to say oh my gosh and you dump right
back into those old rolls
and sometimes that can be manipulative
and controlling
one piece of advice never loan money
never tell them where you work and be
careful about telling people where you
live until you've established trust
and number four this is going to be
unpopular with a number of my mental
health
professional friends okay but i am a
huge fan of reconciliation
a step before reconciliation is this
idea of forgiveness
here's the deal you've got to forgive
you've all heard the story that
choosing not to forgive is like
poisoning yourself hoping somebody else
will die
choosing not to forgive is picking up a
giant cinder block of pain and just
voluntarily deciding i'm going to carry
this around
with me forever just because
now forgiveness doesn't mean you've got
to let somebody back in your life
forgiveness doesn't mean that you stick
your hand back in
to a bag where a rattlesnake is and let
it bite you again
that's just dumb right so reconciliation
happens when you're safe
and when you know where you're headed
moving forward when you are safe
when you have a good community at home
when you've got people in your life you
can be vulnerable
and whole with if you have a counselor
or a pastor or a spouse
or a fiance that you trust
reconciliation can be a powerful healing
moment
you're not going to ever clear up the
past but you can decide
to establish a new relationship going
forward
and it will be slow and it will be
intentional
and it will be painful
all of those things are the price of
admission for love
all of those things are the price of
admission for wholeness
and future wellness so where you can
i strongly encourage reconciliation but
you got to have a group of people with
you
you've got to be safe and you have to
make sure that those things happen on
your terms
so that's it for the video on
reconciling with an estranged mom
or dad if you're safe go for it
keep sending your emails to ask john
ramsey solutions.com
follow buttons go watch some other funny
youtube clips or some great
stand-up comedians probably somewhere in
the tubes and you can probably learn how
to fix your car
whatever's going on in the youtubes dr
john deloney ramsay network i love you
stay in school don't do drugs see you
soon